vuelve al escenario tras 12 años en el
banquillo a sus 76 años Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva está listo para liderar
Brasil una tercera vez esta campaña es
probablemente la más importante de su
larga carrera política para el
expresidente se trata de preservar y
proteger lo que queda de su legado
después de cuatro años con Jair
bolsonaro en el poder
nunca actuaremos como nuestro adversario
que trata de enmascarar su incompetencia
buscando peleas con todo el mundo y
mintiendo siete veces al día después de
dos exitosos periodos como presidente en
2002 y 2006 Lula no pudo presentarse a
un tercer mandato consecutivo y dejó el
cargo en 2010 con un asombroso 83% de
aprobación durante su mandato aumentó el
salario mínimo Y puso en marcha una
serie de programas sociales que sacaron
de la pobreza a más de 30 millones de
brasileños pero la trayectoria de Lula
Jones Hero cuando fue investigado por su
papel en el escándalo de corrupción
conocido como lava yato en 2017 fue
declarado culpable de conceder contratos
gubernamentales a cambio de un
apartamento y fue condenado a 12 años de
cárcel siempre defendió su inocencia y
denunció una conspiración para impedirle
presentarse a las elecciones de 2018 fue
víctima de una de mayores persecuciones
políticas y jurídicas de la historia de
este país
en 2019 Lula fue liberado a la espera de
una apelación
en 2021 su condena fue anulada por un
juez por motivos procesales desde
entonces el expresidente ha estado
preparando su regreso a la política en
mayo de 2022 lanzó oficialmente su
campaña con un ambicioso programa
reabrir la economía apoyar a las
comunidades vulnerables indígenas
proteger la selva tropical y restaurar
la imagen Internacional del país
una tarea difícil para la que Lula
reunió una amplia coalición eligiendo al
político de Centro derecha Gerardo
alkmin su antiguo rival presidencial en
2006 como compañero de fórmula para
ayudarle a derrocar a Jair bolsonaro